Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P Here is a call about tipping,
a subject about which I feel very strongly.
Speaker 4: Do you like to give tips
at restaurants? No.
Speaker 1: But I do it.
Speaker 4: I think that people
should stop tipping at restaurants.
You might say, well, that's bad for the waitress.
Well, if you keep tipping at a restaurant.
The restaurant owner. We'll
continue to not pay a living wage.
To the waitress of our country.
If everyone stops tipping.
Then obviously the waitress and bartender
will leave and not work at the restaurant.
And now the restaurant is stuck with food that
they can serve to their customers. Mm hmm.
And when that happens, they will either
close shop. Or reevaluate their payroll.
Speaker 1: And they will also reevaluate their
prices. So, listen, I want to I've been upfront.
I hate tipping culture and how it has developed.
I don't like the inconsistency of it. I don't like
the increased nature of more and more places where
you're you're allowed to tip. A lot of this is
driven by companies like Square and Stripe who
put those payment tablets. They collect a portion
of every dollar. So it's to the advantage of the
companies that do the payment tablets to offer
tipping for everything. And then, hey, we'll just
collect more money. I tip well everywhere I go,
I tip housekeeping when I stay in a hotel and I,
you know, the valet people, I, I tip everywhere.
But I am very, very much against the entire thing.
The problem with saying if we just stop tipping,
the restaurants will have to adjust. First of all,
the tipping has gone way beyond restaurants at
this point. And the first thing that's going
to happen is if restaurants immediately
play that out. And by the way, some states,
some state law allow the my understanding is that
if the tips don't get that tipped wage up to the
minimum wage, the restaurant owner already has to
make up that difference. That's my belief. But we
should we should fact check that in the immediate
if restaurants all of a sudden because everybody
stop tipping needed to pay employees dramatically
more, they would immediately increase prices
significantly at the restaurant. Now, this is
effectively what has happened. The tips subsidize
and this is what has happened at restaurants that
now say we include a service charge. Please don't
tip. And the prices already reflect that the $12
sandwich might just cost you 15, but they will
say, please don't tip. We have a service charge.
Many restaurants in New York City have already
done this. You look at the menu and it says we
are we pay our employees. Well. The prices already
reflect that or we have added a 4% surcharge for
the back of the house and tip is already inclusive
on the prices or whatever the case may be.
Honestly, I'm I'm more or less for that sort of
thing. And I know that at least in the immediate,
we're just going to pay more in order to not tip.
But there are a bunch of different issues with the
tipping model, and it includes that when people
come from different countries, you don't always
know what's expected. I was recently in the UK.
The UK has now taken to they automatically include
12 and a half percent. So you don't have to think
about it. You can ask for it to be removed,
but the bill comes out and it automatically
says 12 and a half percent tip. And what I like
about that is I don't have to think about it. It
just is what it is. But my preference would
be eliminate tipping, put real pricing that
reflects the total cost of paying employees
well on the menu. And then I can look at the
menu and determine whether I think that this is a
restaurant that I want to visit. But I think that
if we all just stop tipping cold turkey, it'll be
terrible for workers. I don't believe it will have
the effect that our caller believes it will have.
Remember Monday, Memorial Day, this coming Monday,
our one day membership special. If you're thinking
about signing up, I would encourage you to do so
at a humiliatingly huge discount that we will
be offering on Monday. You can be notified via
email by getting on our newsletter at David Pack
Mint.com. Bonus show today will be great. We'll
talk about the $1.3 billion fine that Mata
has been hit with. We will talk about the
move to expel Adam Schiff from Congress and we
will talk about the latest with this Citi Bike
lawsuit that is going on. It's crazy. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
who makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: I can't possibly say it any better
than that. So we will end the show and see
you on the bonus show or back here tomorrow.